Muun muassa - Yle Areena.
Mainoskatkot nykyään niin pitkät että sinne mainosten väliin hädin tuskin mahtuu ohjelma. Minusta tuntuu että tuo on sellainen asia josta tasaisin väliajoin kuulee tai johon tasaisin väliajoin havahdutaan että hetkinen eikös nämä mainokset ennen olleet vähän lyhyempiä ja harvempia.
Eli se on Kansanradio ja Lasse Olkinuora tässä tervehdyssä. Toinen asia johon tasaisin väliajoin havahdutaan itse asiassa kerran vuodessa on se että täältä Suomesta löytyy maailman onnellisin kansa. Siitä aiheesta kuullaankin nyt seuraavaksi ei suinkaan ainoa aihe tämän kertaisessa jaksossa. Esimerkiksi mikkeliläisille tulee kritiikkiä kun eivät putsaa autojensa valoja, pölystä ja liasta. Jyväskylässä puolestaan on liikkunut polttopuunvaro.
No hei! Eläkeläinen täältä Itä-Suomesta soittaa sellaisesta kun tänään kuulin että Suomi on taas onnellisen kansa. Keneltä on kysytty onnellisuudesta? Onko leipäjonossa olevilta, työttömyyttä, asunnottomuutta? No ei varmasti. No ei varmasti. Suomessa ei ole työttömyyttä. Suomessa ei ole työttömyyttä. Suomessa ei ole työttömyyttä. Suomessa ei ole työttömyyttä. Suomessa ei ole työttömyyttä. Suomessa ei ole työttömyyttä.
Kyllä se tuodaan sikariportassa kysellään ja ovat onnellisia. No eipä tässä muuta. Moikka! Suomi se on maailman onnellisin maa. Me ollaan todella onnellisia, että me johdetaan jo yhdeksättä kertaa ajatella, mitenkähän tuokin määri kyllä ei lasketaan. Leipäjonot kasvaa, kuivaa leipää tarjotaan siellä ihmisille. Tää on niin halpa maaakin, että kannattaa nyt eläkkeestä sitten tehdä sitä.
Panna puoleen pois näistä pienemmistä läkkeistä ja hoitojonot kasvaa. Jossain paikassa pääsee hoitoon jossain ajatella, että voiko tuokin muoria vaaritoista nytkähtäs, ettei tarvitse sitä ottaa tänne vastaanotolle. Kyllä jumalautamme ollaan onnellisia. Ei vaan huomautakaan, mitenkä me olemme onnellisia. No päivää kansanedustajien kuuntelijat. Kyllä tämä maailma on nyt vähän sellaista toimintaa alkanut näkemään, että mikä tämä on ihmisen onnellisuus?
oikeasti on ja monta kertaa miettii, että parempi olisi ollut syntyä sinne Intian, -
Valtameren, Pienen saareen, kattoo tätä länsimaista vouhotusta, syvästää kaikki -
onnellisuus noilla pommeilla ja poliisien vainaamisilla ja ei mitään. Niissä työttömyys on -
ihan siis aivan mahdotonta ja voi kunpa olisi syntynyt vaan alkuperäiskansaks sinne Valtameren saareen. Tää on ihan pöliää touhuu täällä. Miten täällä -
voi olla onnellinen oikeasti? Aivan aivokäypiä touhuu täällä. No hyvä kevättä kai. Moi. - Kansanradio on tullut monta viestiä, joissa osassa kyseenalaistettu koko tuo onnellisuustutkimus ja osassa taas kysytty, että mitenköhän tuollaista tutkimusta sitten tehdään? Eli Englannissa jossain päin Oxfordin yliopistoa tämä onnellisuustutkimus kootaan, mutta heidän puolesta sen varsinaisen kyselyn eri kansoille siis tekee amerikkalainen -
firman nimeltä gallup ja kerta sitä nyt kysyttiin niin minä ajattelin kysyä heiltä että miten tällainen kysely tehdään.
Gallupista nopeasti vastattiin että no Suomen kohdalla kyseessä on puhelimitse tapahtuva kysely tai oikeastaan siinä esitetään vain yksi kysymys eli miten ihminen kokee oman elämänsä juuri sillä hetkellä miten hän arvioi oman hyvinvointinsa tyytyväisyytensä onnensa. Tähän tutkimukseen osallistuu noin tuhat suomalaista ja heidän tutkimusmenetelmä eli siis todennäköisyysotanta sen pitäisi taata että tämä joukko on kuin koko Suomi.
Pienoiskoossa eli suhteessa koko kansaan eri ryhmät edustettuina juuri oikeassa määrin ottavat kuulemma sellaisenkin asian huomioon että käytetäänkö kyseessä olevassa maassa vielä lankapuhelinta ja kuinka paljon ettei esimerkiksi pelkästään lankapuhelinta käyttävä jää kyselyn ulkopuolelle.
No näin siis väittävät että onnellisen kansas olisi tässä. Ehkä meidän onnellisuus johtuu siitä että me emme ylpisty ja heittäydy pysyvästi riippukeinuun vaan pyrimme parempaan ja tuomaan esiin epäkohtia niin kuin seuraavaksi kuullaan. Vieraillaan muutamilla paikkakunnilla ja kuullaan että minkälaisia asioita nostetaan esiin. Tämä kierros käynnistyy Vantalta. Muun muassa Vantalta ja nyt voin ohottaa siitä tekoälystä ja meille tulee putkiremontti niin.
Minä mietin että nyt tätä pitäisi verkkokelleri tyhjätä. Vaatehuone pitää tyhjätä. Tulisiko se tekoäly nyt auttamaan siinä asiassa ja sitten tuonne lavalle roskalavalle pitäisi tätä kantaa kaikkia. Kyllä sukulaispoikia pitää pyytää. Ei tämä tekoäly tee yhtään mitään. Se ei laita minulle ruokaan. Se ei siivoo. Se korkeintaan papereita kirjoittaneet tätä ohjelmia mutta ei niin kuin tavalliselle ihmiselle ei ainakaan tämmöiselle vanhusselle.
Siitä ei ole yhtään mitään hyötyä. Moi. No niin täältä keskiseltä Uudeltamaalta niin sanotulta hyvinvointialueelta kun ilta ja yö. Terveyskeskus on suljettu niin kuin iltasi ja öisin ja sitten 40 kilometrin päässä on erikoissairaanhoito. Vanhukset ja lapsiperheet joutuu sitten sinne ja kaikilla ei niitä kahta pemaria pihassa ole.
Että bussilla sitten juna asemalle vääntäydyt ja siellä joutuu sitten vaihtamaan vielä junaa ja sieltä sitten vielä linja-autolla se loppumatka että vanhukset ja huonovointiset ja muut niin kyllä me olemme aika lailla vähän niin kuin heikoilla jäillä täällä että en tiedä mitä meidän päättäjät tuumaa kun ei tätä asiaa.
Saadaan hoitoa mutta odotellaan odotellaan jatkoja. Kiitos Hannus Ulman Uudestaakaupungista. No jääkiekkokeen mennään jo hurjas kun varmaan meidän presidentti tänään puhutellaan tuohon että kurinpitolautakunta antaa jälkikätteen pelikieltoja vastapuolen joukkoon elikkä pelahipkia vasta kun Stubbin pere tuntuu sitten hipkin kannattajia. Tällainen meidän presidentti on että tuhansaa ylistää.
Stubbin kaveri kyllähän saanut huomaa että tämmöisellä haluaa puttaa joka asiaan että ei muuta.
Palot jos ei muuta ja eihän ne näe siitä takalaisista onnettomat yhtään mitään. Näet on muuallakin kuin Mikkelissä ja paljon. Hyvää kevättä.
Eteneen Korpilähtä päivä. No päivä. Totta ni semmoisesta ongelmasta että tiedot tästä. Täällä on semmoisia jotka varastavat toisten polttopuita.
Mistä päin soittelitkaan? Tästä Iväkylästä Korpilahti. Korpilahti joo. Vai varastelevat toisten polttopuita? Joo tuolla kun on noita metsähakkuujelta.
Täällä on jätetty metsänomittajille pyynnöstä polttopuita sinne. Mitään ei uskalla minnekään jättää kun heti kävelletään. Nuntakin se eivät viisitoista kuutiota puita. Oho niin yhdeltä mielten valmiiksi pilkottuja puita ja sitten taas tuolta niin kuin heinosneimen periltä sinne muuramme että ei sieltä jostakin on vietynyt lähiaikoina.
Ja kun me tähän asti on säilynyt kun on justi se tämänomistajan puut niin nyt on sitten tänään evä tarvella. Tylsää homma on tommonen että jonkunlainen tiedotus tuosta pitäisi olla että. Kyllä tommonen harmittaa. Lanketetaan kirosta niiden ylle jotka käy sieltä kähveltämässä. Joo voisko sinne laittaa jonkunlaisen pätkän sinne kansanrataan.
Joo siitä taikka pyritään valotus että omistajat suojeluttavat tuotani varokaihteet ja polttopussä. Mutta kansanradion kautta ihmisille että tällaistakin tapahtuu. Ihan että tietää näistä varkauksista huolimatta mahdollisimman hyvää päivänjatkoa ja keväänodotusta kans. Joo niin kiitos sinulle ja no hei. No miten ne sitten tämän maan asiat paranee.
on seuraavaksi luvassa hyvin erilaista ehdotusta hyvin erilaiseen ongelmaan. Tämä nyt heti seuraavaksi kuultava ehdotus tosin taitaa Suomen lisäksi päteä ihan ympäri maailmana.
Tähän maailman poliittiseen tilanteeseen mulla on hyvä vähän huumori mielelläkin. Mutta kun ne soritaan niin tekoäly on kauhea sitten apetia. Tekoälyt sotikoon niissä maissa missä soritaan ja neuvotelkoon rauhanneuvotelkoon missä yritetään neuvotella. Eikö sitä ole aika hyvä idea?
Me voidaan vaan keskittyä tekemään omat työmme ja nostamaan välillä vähän jalkoja pöydälle ja rentoutumaan ja sillä välin tekoälyhoitaa.
Tekoäly tekee kohta kaikki ihmisten puolella. Sähän ymmärrät mistä minä puhun. Oikeasti minä olen ollut poliitikassa kaikessa. Minä olen semmoinen seitkyt yksi täällä ja seitkyt kaksi tulee synny näin tampirilainen niin vaan maailmaa nähnyt ja kokenut niin siksi minulla on varaa puhua niin kuin minä puhuin. Ja sitten tekoäly rauhanneuttelee niissä maissa missä yritetään rauhanneuta. Tämä on yksinkertainen homma. Ihmiset eivät tarvitse muuten kuin tosiaan nostaa jalat pöydälle ja nauttia elämässä joka ihmisen vauvasta vaadiin vaikka.
- Jos sinä rupeat pitämään ohjelmaa missä kerrot vastaavia ideoita niin minä lupaan että minusta tulee vakiokuuntelija.
- Hyvä. Sitten minä olen saanut taas yhden ihmisen kun olen oikeasti joka tuntei minun neljäkymmentä viisi vuotta sitten että minä olen sunnitinut kulka lusikka suussa mutta en mä tiedä minä olen sitä nähnyt.
Ulmi lusikka minulla oli mutta ei kulta lusi. Mutta hei minä toivottavasti toivon sinulle hyvää viikonloppua edelleen ja sillä ja palaillaan.
- Näin kiitos. - Kiitos voidaan.
- Aamuisin vanhaan kouluissa oli uskontoa aineena. Aamuisin oli aamuhartaus, ruokarukous ja uskontotunnit. Tämä oli turvallisuuden tunteen ja kunnioitusta Jumalan ja vanhempia kohtaan. Nyt on kuriton sukupolvi joka tekee mitä tahansa pahojaan koska vallalla on niin sanottu vapaakasvatus. Aikovat ottaa uskonnon pois kouluista joka on mieletön teko. Suomi on ollut kristillinen maa vaan ei enää. Tämä on surullinen tosiasia ja kohti.
- Ennossa alamaailmaan ja sodan lietsontaan. - Esmetteliä järvien saastumiseen kyllästynyt Bird Life Finland on tutkinut lähijärveä. Valkoposkihanhia oli 117 000. Puolitoista kuukautta kiljuivat ja laskivat järvelle lautaksi. Valkoposkihanhe triista linnuiksi hallitusohjelmaan mitä pikimmin.
- Horrikassa terve. Niin sanotu se se yhdentoista miljardin säästö on hallituksella mennyt tähän aseteollisuuteen ja niin sanotusti voidaan sanoa että se menisikö sen kansan hyväksyttyä tämä kaikki homma. Mitä mitä sinä vois leikata? Mitäskö se leikata niin sanotu se hallitus puolittaa vielä tämä Suomen hallitus koska se tässä säästön paikka on niin sanotu. Näitä ministeriä voi.
Eduskunnasta niin sanoo, siis sillä on niin paljon sitä kumilemmasintaa, mistä ei tiedetä heidän jälkeenä, mitä jälkeenä on se, niin sanoo suorittanut, että on syntakettomia porukkaa osa siellä valiokunnassa. Ja mitkä kuuluu ministeriön, jos osa on virkamies, se on syntakettomia virkamiehiä, joita joten tilien pitäisi tutkia. Asia on näin. Kiitos ja hei.
Korpikes, terve. Tuota niin sen verran, että olen ollut Kansanradiossa puhetta Iivo Niskasesta, niin minun täytyy sanoa näin, että minun arvostukseni on suuri Iivoa kohtaan. Ja se johtuu siitä, että Iivo motivoituu nimenomaan suurkisoihin ja tiettyyn matkaan. Sitten kun monesti Iivo täytyy tehdä tapahtumatta,
arvostelee aika kärkevästikin uoltoa, niin se johtuu ihan Iivon hiihtotekniikasta ja siitä, että Iivo ei halua eikä pysty turhaa voimaa käyttämään, jos sukset eivät toimi, vaan hän yrittää satsata siihen hiihtoon, että se hiihto sujuisi hyvin.
Voideltaisiin kaikista parhaat sukset ja aina sitä seuraavalle huonommat sukset. Mä en nyt oikein osaa sanoiksi pukea mitä tarkoitan.
Eli sen huippuhiihtäjä laitetaan jossain jonkun verran muiden edelle, että siihen keskitytään eniten, niinkö?
Kyllä, mutta tätä taktiikkaa käyttävät varmasti norjalaiset. Okei, se määrä mitä ne saavat mitalla ja minusta tuntuu, että ne voitelee kaikkien sukset hyvin.
Kyllä, mutta silloin kun on tämmöinen tilanne niin kuin Suomessa on, niin silloin pitää mennä siihen. Mutta sitten norjalaisilla on joku, siis tähän minusta tuntuu tietoa, mutta norjalaisilla on joku sellainen jippo siihen voiteluun, mitä nämä muut eivät ole.
Mutta jos me priorisoidaan yhtä urheilijaa, että keskitytään nyt siihen, että tällä kaverilla on sukset kunnossa, niin luulis, että se aiheuttaa aika paljon pahaa verta.
Mutta sehän meni samalla lailla kuljisseessa niin kuin rallissa, että kakkoskuski on kakkoskuski. Eli Iivo ylitse muiden. Se on se.
Laitetaan sitten Iivoja joku naishihtejä, joka on saman arvoinen, jolla on se kova tavoite, että se on voitto tultava. Laitetaan semmoiset hihtejä. On sillä naisissakin sellaisia hiihtäjiä, toivottavasti nousee, jotka ovat samanlaisia. Ja sitten tässä nuori Anttola esimerkiksi varmasti nousee siihen samalle tasolle kuin jossain vaiheessahan hiihtokuningas lopettaa.
Sanon, että yllättävä ehdotus. - Joo ja minä toivon sinulle hyvää tulevaa viikkoa. - Sitä samaa kiitos. Sitä samaa kiitos. - Tehostavasti ei vastaa ja särkynyt tai tämä sun nauhuri. - Ei särkynyt, ei. Hyvä. Kiitos. Heippa. - Maaliskuun loppupuolta eletään. Vieläkö tässä ihmisen pitää olla huolestunut takatalvesta vai joko saa ottaa shortsit eteiseen odottamaan? Lyhyt lahkeisista puheen olle meille on tänne Kansanradioon tullut tällainen kirja, jossa lukee, että arvoisa Kansanradio.
Urheilu on kivaa katsottavaa. Hiihdot, luistelut, yleisurheilut ym. Se mikä kummastuttaa on naisten housujen pienuus. Olisi hienompaa ja arvokkaampaa katsottavaa, jos olisi vähän pienemmällä lahkeella. Enpä usko, että lopputulokseen vaikuttaa pöksyjen koko. Miehet hyvin asiallisissa asuissa, naiset eivät. Alusasuissa urheilemaan se kummastuttaa nimimerkki arvokkuutta naiset.
Olisipa muuten kiva kuulla ammattilaisurheilijoiden tai urheilijoiden ylipäänsä kommentteja aiheeseen, että minkä pituinen lahje tai ehkä täys lahjettomuus on itsellesi mieluisin ja mistä syystä? Mutta nyt kun tuossa oli myös vähän televisiosta puhe, niin pysytään samassa aiheessa. Ehkä piipahdetaan myös radion puolella.
Suomi vähän parantaa profiiliaan. Lupaan olla kuultaottorio Suomeen, jos sinne ei pääse muuta kuin aina. Meillä kuultaota ei ole vaan sinne pääsee soittamaan. Radion omaan pari päivää, jos valiokannat suo. Se on näin.
Tässä puhuu seniori kansalainen. Minkä takia nykyään nämä uutiset tulevat niin kuin niitä sääntöjä, joita täällä puhuttiin viime aikoina?. Minkä tapauksia teillä on tehtävissä?.
Tämä on niin monessa osassa ja vanhemmalle ihmiselle tämä on aika ikävää, kun ennen kuin uutiset alkoivat ja ne loppuivat ja ne oli selvästi puhuttu. Nyt sinne heitetään kaikennäköisiä kuvia väliin. Se on niin sekavaa, että vanhempi ihminen ei pysy mukana siinä.
- Terve! On tässä tullut seurattua eräs tätä niin sanottua laulukilpailua, mutta minä olen nyt tullut siihen tulokseen, että tämä on kyllä kaukana laulamisessa. Kaikki jotka laulaa kauniisti tiputetaan ja jäljellä jäävät ne, jotka huutavat kaikkein kovimmin. Miten olis jos nyt muutettaisiin nämä nimet myöskin?. Tämä on niin tärkeää. Miten ei?.
Huutokilpailu. Siinä tapauksessa jos ehkä tää mieskuoro huutajat ne pärjäis aika kivasti. Moi.
-Karitas. Tervetuloa. Nyt tällä hetkellä tule tuota niin tuosta luontoillassa niitä. Eli tästä merisäästä ohjelma. Ja ihmettelen vielä edelleenkin sitä, että kuka semmoista tarvitsee kun nykyajana on kaikilla laivoissa ja härveleissä on niitä niin nykikilaitteet.
Mistä ne näkee sen säätiardot? Jotkuvasti niitä. Eli mitä tää merisäällä tehdään niitä? Jotkut vanhat ihmiset teitä kuuntelee, mutta eihän nämä mitkä tuo liikenne tee niitä tai ajelee niin semmoisen merisäästietoksen ei tee yhtään mitään. Kiitos. Hei.
-Ovat omituisesti. Aloitetaan meidän WhatsAppista. Tänne on tullut tällainen viesti, että kuuluuko säkättäminen nykyisin suomen kieleen. Yleinen puhetapa tuntuu olevan. Esimerkiksi sä et voi tietää sataako huomenna, vaikka kysymykseen ei ole yhtä kohdennettua kuulijaa. Mielestäni pitäisi puhua, että ei voi tietää sataako huomenna. -Tiellä on yksi tämmöinen vähemmän sivistynyt henkilö Savonmualta. Minä kun olen tuossa tuolla tekemässä.
Kuunnellun niitä viisainmesten tarinoita telekarista taikka radiosta, niin olen huomannut, että sitä on jäänyt hirveästi jälkeen tässä puhetaidossa. Siellä tämmöinen sivistys sana on niinku. Niinku. Ihan vähävälli niinku. Se tulloo sinne ja kyllä kuulostaa viisalta ja pätevältä ne puheenvuorot. Missähän sitä pääsisi tämmöiseen puhekurssille vielä tässä vanhalla päiville, että rupeaisi immeineen tuntumaan niinku pätevältä.
-Kun minä en ole osannut sitä niin kuin sanoin oikein mihinkään laittoon väliin kun en ole oppina enkä saanut opetusta.
-Euro-Euro täällä soittelee. Kun suomalaista omaisuutta on Venäjällä takavarikoitu huomattavia summia niin myös muitten länsimaitten omaisuutta. Ja kun venäläistä rahaa on huomattavia summia länsimaisissa pankeissa, niin eikö se.
Olisi lain mukaan oikein, että se länsimainen omaisuus, jonka Venäjä on omassa maassaan takavarikoinut, maksetaan sillä rahalla sen oikeille omistajille, jotka on tallennettu venäläiselle rahalla, joka on tallennettu länsimaisiin pankkeihin.
-Olva Tampereelta. Tekstit eivät vielä luke, että venäläinen hävittäjä loukkoisi Viron ilmatiloa keskiviikkona. Viron ulkoministeri mukaan Italian ilmavoimien yksikkö reagoi tapauksessa. Mitä helvettiä ne italialaiset täällä tekevät? Ja varsinkin itäisellä Suomenlahdella ovat ne kyttäämmässä niin kuin Venäjän kuvioita. Mitä ne tekee Suomenlahdella? Mitään tekemistä vaikka kuinka leikki jumalasta seuraavaa? Kiittää tulevaisuutta.
-Kun kauheasti joka paikassa säästetään ja säästetään, miksi mukaan ei kerro mihin ne rahat menevät? Emmeristi vaan säästetään. Ja nyt kun uutisia kattoo, niin tuntuu, että koko Suomi ollaan pistevästi aivan nyt. On se sitten kansanisarkista tai on se joku sote-keskus tai on se kirjasta tai on se mikä tahansa, niin kaikki vaan paskakseen nyt.
Tää on tämän hallituksen toimintaa. Ei minulla tässä puhuta. Moi.
- Jos itselleen rakas ihminen vaikkapa mene tyy tai. - Niin kyllä. Kyllä minun mielestäni mieskin saa itkeä. - Totta kai saa. - Ei minusta siinä. Onko se jotenkin rajoite, että mies ei saisi itkeä?
- Ehkä jotkut ehkä siitä on vähän sellaista asennetta sitten, että ei ole niin kovinkaan miehekästä näyttää hirveästi tunteita, mikä tietysti saattaa johtaa siihen, että tunteita pullottaa ja sitten tarpeeksi pitkään kun pullottaa, -
niin mitä tapahtuu? Sitten tapahtuu präjähdys. - Joo. Minä oon kovin herkkä ihminen. Monet ovat tänään, että minä oon kovin herkki. - No mutta sitten ei ainakaan sitä ongelmaa, että tulisi tunteita pullotettua. - Siksi minä olin voinut mennä äidinhautajaksi, kun minä itken värven. Kun kaikki muut on viilitty, pytty ja iso jatka rupeaa värvättämään. Minusta se on todella helvettä. Laitaan varvean näin. Kotona omissa olosissaan saa vähennettää kotona.
Ihmisten ilman kun menee väärin. Minusta jos näytän itsensä, niin nauru alas. - Siinä tilanteessa ehkä jos kyseessä on tai kun kyseessä on lähiomainen, niin tai kun on kokenut suuren menetyksen, niin ehkä ei pidä pohtia sitä, että mitä muut on mieltä siitä, jos näyttää tunteensa. - Se on yhden tekijä, vaan saa olla oma itsensä siinä, että kiitos. Kiitos. Hei hei. - Kiitos kun sä ootit. Kevään jatkoja.
Nars Leijona laittanut meille myös WhatsAppitsen viestiä, kirjoittaa että eipä tässä muuta mielessä kuin maailman rauha.
Vaihdettaisiin vaikka kolmen maailman mahtavinta miestä naisjohtajiin niin asiat vois olla ihan toisin nimimerkki Nars Leijona.
Tähän tämänkertaisen jakson loppuun kuullaan vielä lisää muutamia asioita joihin voisi kiinnittää ehkä vähän huomiota ja olisiko sitten niin että jos niihin asioihin kiinnitettäisiin huomiota niin maa tai maailma.
Olisi pikkaisen parempi paikka elää. Sitä ennen kerron että meidän WhatsApp numero se on 044 5515464. Sähköpostia jos haluat tahettaa niin kansan.radio.at yle.fi.
Tietysti se on 08 0015464. Siellä ihmis vastaa ja odottamassa sunnuntaisin lähetyksen jälkeen aina kolmen tunnin ajan mutta nyt Lasse Olkinuora toivottaa hyvää maaliskuun viime hetkiä.
Pian se on pääsiäänninkin vietetty ja juhlapyhän jälkeinen aikahan on aina paras aika koska silloin on juhlapyhän herkut kaupoissa alennuksessa.
Sitä odotellessa hämmästellään tässä nyt vaikka sitten tuota pikkuhiljaa heräävää luontoa. Lasse Olkinuora toivottaa hyvää vointia ja oikein hyvää päivän jatkoa.
Sieluhan aivan selvästi antaa ymmärtää että Jeesus ylös noustessaan nousi ylös ruumiina kehoon. Kehollaan koko keho nousi. Ei siis sielulähtemys irti olemuksellisesta ruumiista lihaolemuksesta vaan koko henkilö nousi ylös kuolleesta.
Sitä mietin tässä että sitte kuitenkin nykyisinhän meillä kun opetetaan uskossa että sielu jingiltä irtoaa sinne taivaaseen tällä lailla. Mietin tässä että Jeesuksen ylöskausemushan on sitten hyvin paljon erilaisempi kuin mitä me sanomme että kun meidän sielu pääsee ikuisuuteen tai ikuisuuteen ikuiseen elämään niin.
Tämmönen en kehotan ruvetta että pitää ruveta kauheasti uskomaan tuoltaikin mutta mietin tässä tämmöstä. Hei hei. - Sen Kanta Hämeen yli yhdeksänkymmentä. Muumo terve. - No mutta terve mitä kuuluu juuri tänä sunnuntaina. - Ajattelin soittaa tuosta perintö- ja lahjaverosta että valtiovarainministeri hän julkii.
Tietysti tässä äskettäin että että sitä ei poisteta sitä veroa ja mä olen sitä mieltä että niin palkkatulosta saatu palkka sitähän on jo vero maksettu ja eläketulosta saatu vero on jo maksettu kertaalleen että minun mielestä se olisi niin kuin tupla vero sitten kun se sitten vaikkapa omalle lapselle jää.
Niin se se verotus sitten. - Mutta mitä sä sitten kun sano valtiovarainministeri että että että se on niin iso tulonlähde niin sittenhän se pitäisi jostain jostain ottaa korvaava. - Niin mutta se peruste täytyyhän se on vääränmukainen peruste se että että verotetta vaan tuloa tarvitaan vaan niinpä että sen takia verotetaan mutta eikö se olisi oikeudenmukaisempi peruste että kertaalleen verotettaisiin eikä useamman kerran.
- Mutta sitten sanovat että sittenhän se sanovat että jos se poistetaan niin sitten varmaan joudutaan tekemään leikkauksia palveluihin tai. - Mutta se periaate vaan sen takia rupeaa sen soittomat se periaate on. - Tuntuu hölmältä siis että. - Niin se tuntuu kyllä että että voisihan siinä jonkunlainen progressiivinen verotus sitten olla että jos nyt on ihan huippukorkee korkeenvarallisuus ja muuta.
Mutta en tiedä verohan niistä on kuitenkin maksettu että ei tässä nyt mitään sen hurjempaa ole mutta olisi ihan mukava jos valtiovarainministeri vaikka vastaisi tässä kansanradiossa vastais sitten tähän kysymykseen koska tämä on aika iso asia. Minä nyt olen tosiaan yli yhdeksänkymppinen ja ei tiedä minä päivänä kupsastaa tässä niin minulle ainakin on ajankohtainen ja varmaan monelle muullekin. - Minä kiitän kun soitit. - Kiitos.
- Joo kiitos kiitos hei hei. - Kiitos moi. - Se on Harri vaan tässä kun soittelin hyvää päivää kaikille niin on näitä tämmöisiä luontaisvalmisteita mitä on kaukoissa semmoiset isot hyllyt että siellä on D-vitamiina ja C-vitamiina ja siellä on magnesiumia ja siellä on kaikke D-kalkkia ja on sitä sun tätä ja minulla on semmoinen henkilökohtainen kokemus että minä lopetin vuonna kahdeksantoista.
Minä en ole sen jälkeen ottanut edes mitään D-vitamiina enkä yhtään tämmöistä mitä kotiin tuli semmoisia kaiken maailman tilattiin ja puhelimilla soittivat että nyt on omega 3 ja omega 6 ja minulla oli kaapi täällä niitä nappuluotta ja kaikkea muuta niin minä olen kuusi kahdeksan vuotta nyt ollut mennyt siitä ja minä olen vielä elossa niin tämä todistaa sen että kun minä käyn jonkun kanssa aina kaupassa ja minä näen tämmöisen pitkä hyllyrivin missä on näitä myytävänä näitä magneettisia.
Isumi ja poretta ja pirettä ja mitä siellä on myytävänä niin minä olen nimennyt semmoisen että on luulotautilääkehylly niin sen normaalikaupoissa en puhu apteekasta nyt mitään että sillä viisi ei muuta ei.